City workers found a body in a pipe.
All right, here we go.
And, action.
A young woman called Julia Madrigal.
It was six years ago.
I was cut up like Julia.
What someone did to Julia,
they tried to do to you.
After what he did...
everything changed.
Kirby Mazrachi is six years
post a very traumatic incident
where she was attacked,
and she survived.
She's living with trauma,
and it's controlling her life.
When we first meet Kirby,
we see her writing in her diary,
and she's writing down
the most basic things.
Her address,
what the name of her cat is,
where she works,
what her desk looks like.
-What's all this?
-I take notes, same as you.
These are basic facts
that you already know.
When I got out of the hospital,
everything was different.
You don't really know
why this is happening.
For me, the stuff
that really makes the show tick
is the day-to-day trying
to keep control of your life
that keeps falling out of control.
I think a lot of people
can relate to that.
She's trying to figure out
why her world keeps changing
and how it's connected
to her attacker.
In pursuing that,
we also meet a journalist
investigating the story.
A survivor hunting a serial killer,
that's your story.
Dan Velazquez is investigating
at the Chicago Sun-Times.
Little by little,
they both track this killer.
He moved around.
He kept his distance.
He didn't, though. He got close.
He knew all about us.
I'm already with you.
I'm with all of you.
The Shining Girls are the women
that he has chosen over the years to kill.
They have potential.
They have a life ahead of them.
They have this "I'm gonna go
make something of myself."
And that is incredibly threatening.
And that's what he has to take away.
These women don't know each other.
He is the one connecting them.
These actors, Jamie, Wag, Pippa,
all turned in these performances
that were super different
from anything they've ever done before.
I love being involved in something
that manages
to tell a very difficult story
about trauma
and violence against women.
There is this fantastical element to it,
but there's also a lightness to it,
and there's a hope to it.
The people who will like this show
are fans of great thrillers.
They are fans who like
strong female characters,
great drama and great performances.
It's an entertainment show
with something to say.
While I hope audiences
are carried away with the mystery,
I hope they connect
with Kirby's story and her strength.